the reason we're replacing the
roundabout with traffic signals is that
over the last 10 years the traffic
problems have increased from seventeen
thousand vehicles today to 24,000 people
today inside the roundabout just doesn't
driving with that level of traffic
especially at peak times site traffic
signals provide I much better and more
efficient web of managing that traffic
and added advantage of the traffic
signals is for pedestrians and
especially with schools in the area that
will provide a mac cipher right for
children to cross and get to the schools
at this stage of the week is working on
the eastern side of the ride and that's
where the widening is taking place but
also more importantly it'll enable a new
footpath to be constructed during the
school holidays and by the time the
school start again there will be a new
footpath constructed so that will
provide much safer environment for the
school children while they construction
within continues after
with a project of the size and
complexity there will be an impact on
communities and general traffic just be
patient if you're using the section that
consider using an alternative route if
you can and certainly avoid peak times
if you came when the week's finish the
intersection spinach it's going to be
much better intersection and travel will
be flying much more freely so we think
the benefits of the end result will be
fantastic and it's just a case of being
patient while we carry out the
construction week